one of the problems with object
detection as you've seen it so far is
that each of the grid cells can detect
only one object whatever grid cell wants
to detect multiple objects here's what
you can do you can use the idea of
anchor boxes
let's not serve an example let's say you
have an image like this and for this
example I'm going to continue to use a
3x3 grid
notice that the midpoint of the
pedestrian and the midpoint of the car
are in almost the same place and both of
them fall into the same grid cell so for
that grid cell if Y outputs this vector
where you're detecting three classes
pedestrians cars and motorcycles it
won't be able to output to detection so
have to pick one of the two detection x'
to output with the idea of anchor boxes
what you're going to do is predefined
two different shapes called anchor boxes
or anchor boxes shapes and what you're
going to do is now be able to associate
two predictions with the two anchor
boxes and in general you might use more
anchor boxes maybe five or even more but
for this video I'm just going to use to
anchor boxes just to make the
description easier so what you do is you
define the cost label to be instead of
this vector on the left
you basically repeat this twice so you
would have PC B X B YB h BW c1 c2 c3 and
these are the eight outputs associated
with anchor box one and then you repeat
that PC B X and so on down to c1 c2 c3
another eight outputs associated with
anchor bhasu so because the shape of the
pedestrian is more similar to the shape
of anchor box one than and the box - you
can use these eight numbers
to encode that PC is one yes there is a
pedestrian use this to encode the
bounding box around the pedestrian and
then use these to encode that that
object is a pedestrian and then because
the car the box around the car is more
similar to the shape of anchor box to
the nanka box one you can then use these
to encode that the second object here is
the car and have the bounding box and so
on be all the parameters associated with
the detected car so to summarize
previously before you were using anchor
boxes you did the following which is for
each object in the training set in the
training set image it was assigned to
the grid cell that corresponds to that
objects midpoint and so the outputs why
was three by three by eight because
you're the three by three grid and the
grid position we had that output vector
which is you know PC then the bounding
box then C 1 C 2 C 3 with the anchor box
you now do the following
now each object is assigned to the same
print cell as before the signs of the
grid cell that contains the objects
midpoint but it's assigned to an anchor
cell but it's assigned to a grid cell
and anchor box with the highest iou with
the objects shape so you have to anchor
boxes you would take an object and see
so if you have an object with um this
shape what you do is take your to anchor
boxes maybe one anchor box is this shape
that's on the box one maybe anchor box 2
is this shape and then you see which of
the two anchor boxes has a higher IOU
with the ground true banging bolts and
whichever it is that object then then
gets assigned not just to a grid cell
but to a pair just assigned to a grid
cell calmer and cabal hair and that's
how that object gets encoded in the
toggle label
and so now the output Y is going to be 3
by 3 by 16 because as you saw on the
previous slide
y is now 16 dimensional or if you want
you can also view this as 3 by 3 by 2 by
8 because they're now 2 and the boxes by
and Y is a dimensional and dimension of
Y being 8 was because we have 3 object
classes if you have more objects then
the dimension of Y will be even higher
so let's go through a concrete example
for this grid cell let's specify what is
y sodium pedestrian is more similar to
the shape of ANCA box 1 so for the
pedestrian we're going to assign it to
the top half of this vector so yes there
is an object there be some bounding box
associated the pedestrian and I guess if
a pedestrian is cost 1 then we see 1 is
1 and then 0 0 and in the shape of the
car is more similar to anchor box 2 and
so the rest of this vector will be 1 and
then the bounding box associated with
the car and then the car is c2 so that 0
1 0 and so that's the label Y for that
lower middle your grid cell right that
did I that this arrow is pointing to now
one of this grid cell only had a car and
had no pedestrian if it only had a car
then assuming that the shape of the
bounding box around the car is still
more similar to anchor box 2 then the
target label Y if there was just a car
there and the pedestrian had gone away
it would still be the same for the
anchor box
2 component I remember that this is a
part of the vector corresponding to and
box two and for the part of the vector
corresponding to anchor box one what you
do is you just say there is no object
there so PC is zero and then the rest of
these would be don't care us now just
some additional details what if you have
to anchor boxes but three objects in the
same grid cell that's one case that this
algorithm doesn't handle it well you
know if you hopefully it won't happen
but if it does this algorithm doesn't
have a great way of handling it we just
implement some default tiebreaker for
that case or what if you have two
objects associated the same print cell
but both of them have you know the same
anti box chain again that's another case
that does everything doesn't handle well
if you can spend some your default way
of tiebreaking if that happens hopefully
this won't happen then your data say
that won't happen much at all and so it
shouldn't affect performance much so
that's it for anchor boxes and even
though I've motivated anchor boxes as a
way to deal with what happens if two
objects appear in the same grid cell in
practice that happens quite rarely
especially if you use a 19 by 19 rather
than a three by three grid you know the
chance of two objects having the same
midpoint out of these 361 cells it does
happen but it doesn't happen that often
the may be even better motivation or
even better results that anchor boxes
gives you is it allows your learning
algorithm to specialize better in
particular if your data set has some
tall skinny objects like pedestrians and
some wide objects like cars then this
allows your learning algorithm to
specialize so that some of the outputs
can specialize in detecting wide you
know fat objects like cars and some of
the upper units can specialize in
detecting tall skinny objects like
pedestrians so finally how do you choose
the anchor boxes and people used to just
choose them by hand you know choose a
maybe five or ten anchor ball shapes
that spans a variety of shapes that
seems to cover the types of objects you
to detect as a much more advanced
version just an advanced comment for
those of you that have other knowledge
of machine learning an even better way
to do this in one of the later euro
research papers is to use a k-means
algorithm to group together two types of
object shapes you tend to get and if we
use that to select a set of anchor boxes
that this most stereotypically
representative of the may be multiple
there may be dozens of object causes
you're trying to detect but that's a
more advanced way to automatically
choose the anchor boxes and if you just
choose by hand of a variety of shapes
that you're reasonably spans the set of
object shapes you expect to detect some
tall skinny ones some fat white ones
that should work easily as well so
that's it for anchor boxes in the next
video let's take everything we've seen
and tie it back together into the yellow
algorithm